die osthessische stadt fulda hat ein
taubenproblem und deshalb dieses
stattliche taubenhaus in die fuldaaue
gesetzt
drei stockwerke mit hunderten
brutplätzen hier will die stadt den
tieren gipser zum ausbrüten
unterschieben und so den bestand
verringern kosten insgesamt stolze
70.000 euro
doch das schicke bauwerk hat einen ganz
entscheidenden haken es steht so weit
außerhalb dass es die tauben aus dem
stadtzentrum überhaupt nicht
interessiert ich frage mich warum man
das hier hin gebaut hat weil eigentlich
hier die wenigsten tauben sind in der
stadt sind die tauben nicht hier in der
stadt werden die häuser zerstört durch
den kot und der salzmann was tun
am meisten leidet die historische
bausubstanz in der barockstadt aber auch
banker und sitzflächen sind völlig zu
geschissen weggeworfenen essensresten
und illegale fütterungen verschärfen das
problem zusätzlich
die lösung soll das taubenhaus bringen
aber wohin mit dem turm weil ihm in der
stadt keiner vor der nase haben will
kommt er schließlich jwd in die fuldaaue
an den stadtrand aber im opulenten
taubenschlag verlieren sich ein paar
tiere das erste stockwerk ist sogar
komplett leer mangels kundschaft
erklärungsversuche vonseiten der stadt
versteht sich nicht an der völlig
falschen stelle
der platz ist wie übereinstimmend
geäußert wurde geeignet durchaus er ist
nicht optimal aber es geeignet und er
war zum damaligen zeitpunkt eben der
verfügbare platz ein politischer
kompromiss der die tauben aber nicht
interessiert die bleiben da wo sie schon
immer waren
trotzdem herrscht im rathaus das prinzip
hoffnung für eine abschließende
bewertung ist das nach dem zeit drauf
jetzt von zweieinhalb jahren noch zu
früh experten sagen für eine
abschließende bewertung müsste man etwa
fünf jahre kalkulieren viele fulda
wissen allerdings heute schon was sie
von dem teuren tauben haushalt
nicht viel 70.000 euro sind natürlich
auch eine menge geld und da die trauben
nicht sind ist verschwendung ja okay
vielleicht sollte die stadt sich
überlegen vielleicht noch ein tauben
leitsystem zu investieren damit die
tauben wissen wo das taubenhaus steht
keine schlechte idee aber ob das was
bringt die stadt will jetzt externen rat
einholen damit die vögel die tauben aus
vielleicht doch noch finden